From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
In 2006-2011, my name is Joe Mosnier of the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
This is a collaborative project that we are undertaking for the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
We are in Atlanta, Georgia, on the campus of Georgia State University with Dr. Doris Derby, who has graciously agreed to sit down to be one of the interviewees in our inaugural year for the Museum's work to develop a foundational oral history collection to support its work.
Dr. Derby, thank you so much for sitting down with us. It's a pleasure to be with you.
Quite welcome.
Let me start today with a... I'd love to have you talk a little bit about your childhood, your parents. I know that your great aunts were also very influential figures as you kind of came into yourself as a young adult and just reflect a little bit about what seems to have been a quite exceptional childhood in so many respects.
Well, you know, I was thinking about my grandparents and my relatives and the atmosphere that they created as...
I think for all of my aunts and uncles and those of us as we grew up, my grandmother, on my mother's side, my maternal grandmother, she lived in Bangor, Maine.
And there was a... and I knew her, you know, we used to go visit during the holidays or in the summer. When I was growing up, we were very close in terms of our family.
My mother came from a family of 11 children. And my grandmother was originally from Haiti in the Virgin Islands and her husband, my grandfather, was from Virginia.
Now, interesting enough, I didn't know about it, but I later found out that my grandmother and her oldest son was the... were original charter members of an NAACP chapter founded in the 1920s.
I didn't know about that until I read the book that a historian wrote. It was called Black Bangor, the Black Community in the late 1800s and early, you know, 1920s, 30s.
My grandfather, on my mother's side, had a store. It was in Bangor, Maine. He was a businessman, and everybody loved him and loved... and his store was called a Bangor institution.
On my father's side, I have grandparents that were very active in the community. And my paternal grandfather was a Boy Scout leader just as my father was.
I think that there's a theme there in both sides of the family. Hard work, determination, goals, and within the climate of some racism.
But they took the route of working hard to overcome it through their initiatives.
And so I think that that's something that, you know, those are values that I inherited on both sides. Strong family, strong community, work hard and, you know, achieve... achievement for our self, family, and community.
And that's what led me to also embrace the struggle in the South.
I'd like to hear a little bit more about the community. It's fabric. It's the kinds of things that you were involved in as a young person, church, social service, school.
Well, I grew up in a community in the Bronx, called Williamsbridge. And it was an interesting community. It was diverse, and yet we had a...
The black community was welded together through the three or four churches in the area.
My father was a Episcopalian, and so we went officially to the Episcopalian Church. But my three girlfriends who lived on the street on the same block as I did, they went to the Baptist Church, down the street.
And so I went there also. So I really went to two churches every Sunday. And I sang in the choir, the youth choir, in their church.
And I was active in other ways in the Episcopalian Church. There was several people from the Caribbean islands, and well as the South, South Carolina, North Carolina.
And so I had a mixture there in the community. Every time I went to another level of school, from elementary to junior high to middle school, I had to walk a longer distance.
But the environment, the people were more varied. But the neighborhood was very varied too. We had a Jewish delicatessen, an Italian's own the liquor store.
And so we had a Chinese restaurant, and Chinese laundry, and black restaurant owner. So it was quite varied. The Italians were the largest population in our community.
So as I said, as we got older and went to another school, we got more people coming from a farther away, some from what we call the lower Bronx.
And so you had that mixture, many of them, somewhere Latin, somewhere again Caribbean, sometimes a few African, as well as Greek, Italian, Jewish, all of that.
So I grew up along those lines. But I also had a quest for the early age as to where are our black positive images in the media.
I'm not seeing very much of it in books and magazines. Now in newspapers, there are black newspapers. But in film.
And we gravitated to what movies they were, which was the Amos and Andy, or Tarzan, where there were some black African people who were running around.
I had a great aunt, who was, it was like a great, great, great aunt. My grandmother, my father's side, she called her aunt, great aunt Jesse.
She, great aunt Jesse, was a missionary in Liberia. And she would write letters to my grandparents, my paternal grandparents, telling about her experiences in Liberia, in Monrovia.
And sent some photographs, mainly the stories. And so I said, well, I have to find out more about this continent that has all black people or a variety of black people, where we came from.
So that was one of my missions. Now I also grew up in the arts, all of the children and my mother's family played musical instruments, except for my, well, my mother did also, but she studied dance.
And my sister and I studied dance from elementary school. And that, of course, pursued expand your horizons. And combined with the ideas from my great aunt about Africa, I wanted to know more.
So when I was in junior high school, I, anytime we had a social studies report, I did something on Africa, on a Caribbean. I was very privileged to grow up in New York City, because in Manhattan, we had something called Schomburg Library.
In Schomburg Library is a collection of African African African American heritage, Caribbean heritage books. And one time when I was going to visit my aunt, who lived in that area, and I found out that they were having auditions for a scholarship to the Katherine Dunham Dance class.
And I, and I tried out and I got it. So I would have to go to Harlem once a week for my dance class. And then I'd stop at the Schomburg Library. And I got to meet some new kind of people. So I got interested in, in pursuing and learning more about the African heritage and African, African American images.
The variety of people, etc. And so when I didn't see books and magazines and in the media, it was in my mind that I would have to do it myself.
My father was a, he used to take pictures at all of our family gatherings. And he had his camera and his, he had the, the photographs made into slides. So that whenever we had family gatherings, he would get the projector and the screen and the slides out.
And so that's what I did later on also. And that's what I'm still doing.
Yeah. Can I ask did you actually meet Miss Dunham?
Yes, I did. I met her a couple of times. Now she didn't teach the class herself. It was, had her name. But I did later on have a chance to meet her.
How did you come by, by your teenage years to be interested in joining the Youth Chapter of the NAACP?
Well, we had a chapter at our church. Our church had a, the old building of the church became like a community event place.
The Boy Scouts met there. The Bible School took place there. We had different organizations met there. We had fashion shows there, bankwits, all of that.
So the church, often in the black community, was the facility for community events and community organizations. So actually that's why when I became a part of the church.
I was a part of so rights movement. Having functions in churches, mass meetings and rallies and all that. It wasn't so different to me. There were a lot of things that, even though I grew up in New York, the part of me that I grew up in was really outside.
It was within the city limits, but it was right at the edge. And people used to say, oh, you live in the country. And in the way we did.
Because we used to raise chickens and ducks. My father had, we had big vegetable garden. We had trees, apples and cherries. We raised, I mean, good grapes. We had a big grape harbor. We made grape juice, grape jelly, wine, etc.
So, and not too far from my house, we used to go on the weekends and we'd go sort of exploring. And there were areas that were forested and had brooks. And they would deer up there and that kind of thing.
Now that was for a certain period of my life, but as I got older, of course, those things changed.
Which is saying that your household was a, was a politicized one. So I'm picking of mid fifties, say the sequence of brown, Montgomery, Little Rock, or those things that were frequent and subjects around the, around the dim table in the household.
Oh, definitely. I mean, we, with my grandparents and my aunts and uncles, like I said, we came, we had a lot of family gatherings. And then when we get together, we, my parents. And we were always, the children were part of the conversation.
And we were listening to what happened to my grandparents and what happened to my father when he was growing up. For example, he was the only African-American male in his civil engineering class at the University of Pennsylvania.
And he told us a story about when he won, he was in gymnastics and fencing. And he won some awards. He was an engineer, civil engineering. But when he went to collect his awards, they had the award ceremony somewhere else other than the university.
And they, whoever was at the door said he had to go to the service elevator. So he left. He did not go to pick up his awards. That was when he was in his early twenties and the thirties.
So there are stories like that. There are stories of my grandfather and my father would talk about writing the rails, catching the train, jumping on the trains and going to New York from Philadelphia where they were living at the time.
And they had moved from Boston to Philadelphia, my grandfather and the children to find work. And then as he got older, my grandfather and he and probably his brother would jump on the trains to go to New York to get some work.
So we knew about economic disparity. We knew about the trials and tribulations, the variety of work that they had to take just to make a living. I knew about the fact that when my father got his civil engineering degree, he was discriminated against. And then the only job he could get with them was whatever he did, it was in their name.
My uncle that was married to my mother's oldest sister, he talked about his story. He was, he, he did training at Tufts University to be a dentist. And he couldn't really, he didn't have anyone who would a dentist who would take him in as a partner in intern.
Then he couldn't get the money to work to put his, to have a dental office together. So he ended up, he was a wife, my aunt, they had three children. They ended up leaving Boston and coming to New York.
And what did he do? He ended up being a sky cap at the airport. But you see his intelligence was still there. So there, there were discussions about these things, these disparities at the dinner table during the holidays.
Another aunt who was married to a man from New York, they would, you know, we would have them for the holidays. Now that aunt, my aunt Julia, at Tufts named Julia, one was on the mother's side and one was on my father's side.
And on Julia was, she was an executive secretary. Now all of my mother's siblings finished high school. They were like nine or eight or nine of them, the ones that did not pass away got high school degrees. And they all played instruments.
And they talked about how the different things that they went through.
We're back on after a break for a fire alarm. So we had to leave the building for a few minutes and we're now back. Dr. B, you were talking about your Aunt Julia?
Yes, Aunt Julia Green, who lived on 135th Street, Norman, for a period of time, for a long period of time. You know, as I was growing up, however, before that, you know, she, she had migrated from Bangor, Maine because it was hard to find a job. She was, the din Boston for some years. And W.E.B. Du Bois.
She later left that and went to New York. When she was in New York as an executive secretary, she was recruited by the US government as one of, let's say, ten or twelve black women to be secretaries in Washington, D.C.
When they were integrating the workforce in Washington, through the government.
This would have been about what year?
That would have been, I guess, was in the 30s, 40s? No, not 40s, 30s.
No, wait a minute. It was after World War II. I think it was at the early, like, middle 40s, I would think. So she did work there for a period of time and then she came back to New York.
So of course, she had her experiences. Her husband also, he worked for, I think, the Civil Service in New York. He had his experiences.
And so whenever relatives got together, they talked about their experiences. What they were doing, what had happened, how they were coping with it, what else they were going to do, you know, what the children were doing, what their goals were for their children, and so on and so forth.
So I mean, it wasn't, we didn't really, as growing up, we didn't consider that we were not going to go Tougaloo College. But of course, we lived in New York City, where we had city colleges.
And we, in this university, Georgia State is a city college, and it's a community college. And that's what my sister and I went to.
My brother, who came along nine years later, he ended up going off to Howard University.
So I think that, I know that these roundtable discussions that we would have over dinner and celebrations certainly influenced me. And that as, when I was a college student, I began to have discussions with people.
I would meet that seemed to be interested in what was going on in the government in, you know, in Africa and just culturally what we're, you know, where, where are we as African American people and where is the United States?
How are we going to make some changes because there are things that need to be done?
I know that one of the, one of the places that, um, Hunter College, where you, you began those kinds of conversations was, was the Christian Human Relations Club.
And I, I want to ask about that generally, but also, I think in 61, you might tell me it's 1962.
No, sorry, it is 1961 if I'm, if I'm not mistaken. The, the Christian Human Relations Club organized a bus trip to Durham, North Carolina. And I wondered, I'd love to have you described. And I also wonder if that was your first trip to the South.
Okay, let me just say a few things before that.
My grandparents believed in traveling and none of them were ever in the military, but they, they would take the very active in the church.
And my family, my father, I was very active in the church and two churches, as I told you. And so my grandparents church would take trips, they would go in trips to Canada and upstate in New York,
somewhere, and sometimes they would take me with them.
When I was a girl scout in teenager, my girl scout leader had adopted a child and she was from Detroit.
So she, I used to babysit for her and she wanted me to go to Detroit to take you to a child for a couple weeks.
And then I started traveling, that whole, you know, activity of interacting with people and learning about new places and so on was a part of my learning curve.
Again, a part of the church, I, at my church activity, I was also interested in Native American people heritage because we had always heard that we had, we were part Cherokee.
So, the, there were different projects that you could participate in as a college student during the summer.
And the one I found out about was going to a Navajo Indian reservation in New Mexico. So I did that, that summer.
And when I was, when I came back and I was thinking that I wanted to go to Africa, I happened to run into an old friend of mine.
And I said, well, guess where I just went, you know, and New Mexico. And he said, well, guess where I'm going to Nigeria for the exchange in the college.
So I said, well, I want to go, you know, he said, I'll tell you about it when I get back and he called me, when he got back and told me he was a, he was at Yale Law School.
And he told me, and so he said, you know, he can apply to the NAACP and they may get a scholarship, and which I did do and I did get scholarship.
I was an NAACP member, had been since I was 16. So there I went, I was the baby of the group, most of them were grad, grad school, professional school.
So that summer of 1960 was the summer that I spent in Africa before I had any trip to the South.
And it was quite interesting when I finally did go and live in the South and how I saw some similarities in the culture and so on.
But at any rate, so when I came back, I was active, continued to be active on campus in the Anthropology Club and also the, there were a couple of us that found us something called the African Scholarship Committee, in which we raised funds for the students who came over under the Kennedy, John F. Kennedy, airlift.
And they lifted students to come over from some of the newly independent countries and that they didn't have very much money.
So we did that. And so the other group that I was active with was the Christian, kind of college Christian relation group.
So yes, we had a mixed group, blacks and whites. The Hunter College was, Hunter College in the Bronx was a smaller school than Hunter College in Manhattan, which is the main school.
And so we had a nice group of about what, 10, 12, 14 students that went in.
And our purpose was to talk with some of the student leaders and the community leaders about segregation and the sit-ins and the freedom rides and so on.
And to find out what we could do, we wanted to learn more about what was going on and to see what we could do to support them.
And so when we came back, there was a group that had started or maybe it had already started, but we worked with them in other than student support movement.
We wanted to publicize and form people about what was going on and have some speakers to come.
Ethel Kennedy came to Hunter College. Malcolm X actually came and some other people.
So that was very informative.
Do you remember time?
Excuse me, do you remember your Durham visit and as your sensibility about these things was widening.
You've been to New Mexico. You thought about your experiences in Durham.
Did you have what kinds of things were unfolding in your mind in these years as you were now looking towards your last year of college?
And did you anticipate at that point becoming so deeply involved in the Southern Freedom Movement?
Well, I was being involved.
Don't forget the African countries were becoming moving towards independence.
Nigeria, for example, when I went there in the summer of the 1960s, they were not yet independent.
They became independent at that October.
While actually when we went to Nigeria on the way, we also stopped in France in Paris in Rome, Italy, Paris in Rome.
So again, my eyes are being open. I'm looking at seeing achievement and not achievement and so on.
So these things were happening and they were not far into me because they fitted with what I had heard through my oral history of my relatives, the struggles.
When I went to the novel Indian reservation and I saw what was happening with the Indians, the novel Indians.
And as a person who was a culture anthropologist, I believed in living in the community and finding out what kind of life the people have.
It was interesting that there was a black community, migrant community in the town of Farmington, Mexico.
And then there was a reservation, then I only knew the Indians.
And I went to all of that. I mean, I love to be a part of other cultures.
So I could see economic inequality in a lot of different places.
And sort of semi-segregation in that respect in Mexico.
And then, of course, I had been meeting that African. I had been associated with people who were exploring African culture.
It was the AmSAC, the AMSAC.
And I started to go to their meetings in New York. They were looking at making connections, cultural connections, identifications, and cultural connections between Africa and African Americans.
Whereas it had been portrayed in movies or understated, grossly understated movies and TV and so on.
If you weren't adventurous and trying to research information in the library, you wouldn't find out very much.
But I was adventurous and continued to do research and read lots.
But in addition to reading, I was very excited about African culture, the dance, and the art we're discovering that the music just excited me.
So I was studying African dance. I was listening to African music. I was brought back African art.
And I would show it. I started to take it and show it to people at different meetings, African sculpture, African trinkets, and whatnot.
So this just became something that I did. When I did go to the South, I had things with me.
And I used to show African art in the Head Start programs and churches.
I took African dresses and all kinds of things. That's just what I've done. I wanted to share what I learned about African culture so that people would know that there is not a void.
It's just the void from the American side purposely to keep us from knowing what our culture was.
I started to look for when I was in junior high and going on through high school, looking to identify artists, writers, dancers.
So I was at about experiencing African and African American and Caribbean culture from a very early age.
In the summers?
I continued to study African dance throughout college and graduate school. When I was in Mississippi, I had a dance group.
When I was working at Turo College, I continued to paint. Then I added the photographs.
I always used to take pictures, but that was just family and friends. But then later on, I wanted to document so that the things that I felt I was lacking when I grew up, that I had to really find out about.
I had to look for. I wanted other people to have those visual images. I wanted to show what the average person was doing as well as the leaders, as well as the people whose names you know, the artists and whatnot.
I wanted to show our culture in total and not just a little bit or negative stereotypes. That's really what I still do.
Let me ask about it. I will ask more questions that will draw out all those themes. Let me ask about your transition in the summer of 1962. You originally had a plan, I think, to go back to New Mexico to do some more anthropological work.
I had a friend who was an anthropologist also. She had gone to Mexico to do a master's in cultural anthropology. I had been reading and studying African images.
I was interested in the African images in Mexico, in the Mexican sculptures in Oaxaca. I had met someone who had the masters in art.
I can't think of anything now. You could do art history as well as visual art. I was doing a lot of painting at that time. I wanted to investigate what I would like to do a master's there and visit her because it was the summertime.
I started teaching in that January of 1962. I had the summer off, teaching the third grade. I had planned this trip and I decided, back then, I didn't mind going on the bus.
I decided to take the bus trip and go to Georgia to Atlanta, Georgia, and then to Albany, Georgia, where I had one of my colleagues from Hunter College and we were part of the Northern Student Movement together.
She had gone to Albany, Georgia. She decided she was going to drop out of school and work there in voter registration and other areas.
I had heard that she was sick and that she was in jail. I said, I'll go and see her. She's doing me a spend a week and then I'll go to New Mexico. I mean, to Mexico.
As it turned out, I was told, well, if you're going to go to Albany, Georgia, you have to go to Atlanta first and meet up with the SNCC folk, Student Nonviolent Coordinating Committee, because I had already started working to establish a New York SNCC office.
So that work had already begun in New York?
Yeah, it was developing.
I think. That was 62, I think. Things were developing and was getting well.
What did you find when you arrived in the SNCC office in Atlanta?
Well, I thought that I'd be there like a day and we'd go off to Albany, but you had to make sure there was transportation. There was a lot of activity going on.
There were projects and people coming in and moving around and it was a whole operation.
I had to wait to see who was going and how we were going to get there and so on.
So I mean, I just said, okay, well, I'll wait and I'll get to know who's in the office. So I did met a lot of the key players.
I didn't form in and several people. Bob Zellner.
Ruby Doris Smith. Several.
So finally, when there was a car ready and there were a couple people that were going to Albany, because I didn't know how far Albany, Georgia was.
It was three hours away.
So I think there were four of us that went in the car. At that point, it was dangerous to arrive at an integrated car.
There was Jim Forman, Bob Zellner myself and I think there was one other person.
But we arrived in Albany, Georgia and they went to the SNCC office and they arranged to put us up with the family.
And then the next day they came and they said, okay, well, we need to do some canvassing.
And I go to the SNCC office and see what was on the agenda for the day.
The SNCC office. The Albany movement.
Albany movement office in Albany. And see what was on the agenda.
What had transpires. What the police were doing. What was, you know, what was Dr. King doing and what was needed to do.
So before I knew it, I was in that mode. But I have always been in a community acting, helping mode.
It's like, okay, what do we need to do? What are we doing? What do we need to do?
And so by that time I found out that my friend Peggy had been, she was in, I think it was Americus, Georgia.
She was in America's or in Terrell County. She's called Terrible Terrible, Terrible County.
And I was just starting to learn more about, you know, students getting arrested and demonstrations going on and a chief of police, no help from him and so on and so forth.
And some of the members would get arrested so they need everybody who can do different things in it.
They need all hands on deck so to speak.
Well, I could see how things were going and I had a lot of skills and they were asking me to do this and that and everything.
So I ended up doing several things and before I knew it, the summer was almost going to be over and I decided I wasn't going to New Mexico and Charles Sherrod of Albany, Georgia said, well, we need you to go back and do some fun raising for us.
And so the way we need some canned goods, we need food, we need clothing for the people who have been kicked off their jobs and all of that.
So that was my next task.
Back up in New York?
Yeah.
My back took teaching school into raising money and different kinds of goods for the old movement.
I'll ask about that.
Just one second.
I wanted to have you reflect a little bit about that full summer in Albany.
Obviously, you mentioned that you came with many skills that you were able to deploy directly because you were capable in many ways that were very relevant to the movement.
Were there ways in which you didn't feel equipped maybe because, say, of the question of violence and threat that you're isn't really a convenient answer to that.
Do you feel were there ways in which it was upsetting or difficult?
Well, there were so many things, so many activities going on and there was excitement.
There was the mass meetings and people were planning things.
There was a training in nonviolent techniques for demonstrations, which I did at the Spade and Sum.
So it really wasn't, I wasn't thinking so much about something happening to me.
I mainly was interested in doing what I could do and what I was needed to do.
When I grew up, my father was in grandparents, very self-sufficient, and had a lot of skills.
It was like, we do whatever we need to do.
We grew our own food.
We raised our chickens and ducks with fruit trees and flowers.
We painted the house when we needed to.
My father had copied three skills just as his father.
He supplemented his income, which when he didn't get an engineering job, he ended up working at the Civil Service in the New York State Civil Service.
He was a cabinet maker in the evenings.
I used to go to the basement with him and he showed me how to make things out of wood.
I used the pieces of masonite that he had left from his cabinet. That's what I painted on.
I was always recycling things.
That was part of my imagination that I would make something out of something that I would pick up and look at.
I think of what kind of design it had.
My mother taught me how to sew.
We made our Easter outfits by the time we were in fifth and sixth grade.
I was always very adaptable.
I was traveling.
I used to be in other places, or staying with other people.
We traveled to our relatives.
We traveled to the church to new places.
I especially, in my family, did that.
I started thinking that was my inheritance from my aunts and my grandparents.
When you went back to New York, you did a lot of work with others to really bring the New York SNCC Office forward.
Can you talk a little bit about that effort and how it connected then to the organizational effort for the March on Washington?
Well, that was 62-63 especially.
When I came back from Albany, I saw the teaching again.
I knew that I had to do fundraising.
I connected with another group, Ray Brantstein.
I can't think of her group right now.
I had to do some papers from that.
This is an interesting lady.
She was a white lady.
She was in a wheelchair.
Somehow, a brother, I have to look at some of the old documents.
We got together.
We wanted to be able to get a bus, school bus.
She had some kind of educational program.
We wanted to get a school bus, fill it full of food, canned goods, clothing and books.
We worked together on that project and her organization.
At the same time, I expanded the people that I knew that could help SNCC.
SNCC needed a New York office for fundraising.
There were a group of us who went there in the afternoon or the evening.
I got out of school at 3 o'clock and sometimes go down there in the early evening.
There were people I was meeting through that group as well as developing sick.
The March on Washington — Bayard Rustin's group.
We were a part of a committee to come together to recruit people to work to organize the March on Washington.
Being in contact with the SNCC people and the King's people and all these other organizations.
You also, in this period, co-founded New York Artists for SNCC.
That must be a very interesting story.
Well, that was just starting around, I guess, in that spring of 63.
Later on, I would come up from Mississippi because I went to Mississippi to work
after the March on Washington. I'm kind of fuzzy now with the dates.
I especially was talking with the visual artists to get them to perhaps donate some work or doing images
of the civil rights, different incidents and whatnot.
I had already become friends with a lot of artists, visual artists, writers.
When I was in high school, I was a part of the Harlem Writers Guild.
As I said, I was going to the AMSAC AMSAC meetings
where I was learning more about what they call a neighborhood.
What they call a neighborhood.
African tying in African philosophy and African culture and African American
and Korean American, Korean American, Korean American.
I also was with writers and actors and just talking about how we could fundraise to raise money
for a snake in Atlanta and then put on concerts to raise money and so on.
Some of the actors and entertainers would have parties.
But then after I went, that was kind of a relatively short period
because then I was concentrating on being in Mississippi.
But I would come up to New York, back to New York, and then sort of be here or there for a short period of time.
Let me ask about Bob Moses' invitation that you consider coming after the March on Washington down to Jackson, Mississippi
and how that conversation with Bob Moses unfolded initially and how you weighed that prospect
and then how you made that decision and what you encountered when you arrived.
Well, I mentioned that my charge from Charles Sherrod was we needed, you know, yet we need funds and we need to, they needed a vehicle.
So the school bus and so I put, I had my little committee and I was organizing a big fundraising event at a church in the United States.
So I was told that like, oh, it would be great to have Bob Moses.
He can come up and speak and you can, you know, get contributions or something.
So that's what we did.
And so after that was a great success, that Bob Moses asked me, would I be willing to come to Mississippi to work in an adult literacy project
that he was working on getting, pulling together as a pilot project.
And so, you know, at that point, I told him, I really had some other things that I was going to do.
I was teaching, I was, you know, happy doing what I was doing, working with Snake in New York and with the artists and continuing on.
I'm meeting artists and in my mission of getting images and I was painting.
So he left, went back to Mississippi and he called me a couple of times and said, you know, would you really need you, we want it.
We think we're going to get this grant for a year.
And we want to develop adult literacy materials and then junction with Snake's vote registration efforts, developing materials that would meet the needs of people when they go to register to vote or to vote.
And all kinds of outrageous requirements were made.
So we wanted to see if we could gear the development of literacy materials to some of those things and also to some of the areas that adults needed writing to function and to give them a better life, such as knowing about credit and shopping and other things like that.
So he called me a couple of times and I said, no, I really didn't want to go. I had still had it in my mind that I would go off for my master's in anthropology and pursuing.
I was really interested in African influences in many ways in other places.
So for example, in India, African influences in Mexico as well as definitely in the United States and in the South particularly.
But when I, that spring going to May, June, when you had the demonstrations in Birmingham and Alabama and some other places and you had the violence, you had the police bringing out the dogs and
the fire hoses and so these photographs, these vivid images of all of this violence and I was watching the news and I saw this come on and I said, okay, I got up and I told my parents I said, look, you know, I'm going to go to Mississippi to work on this literacy project.
Because if the people there can continually children and adults and they're going there and just demonstrating and they're suffering like this, the least I can do is participate in this literacy project.
I am a teacher, I've already been, I haven't, you know, I'm committed to the struggle in many different facets and that's what it is.
So I called Bob and I said, okay, I'll go. I'll go to Mississippi after the March of March in 2010.
Okay. We just took a little short break. You just explained how having seen so much of the violence in media and imagery and so forth that's bringing 63 that you, that that result, that was the moment you resolved to go to Mississippi after the March on Washington.
Let me ask you about the March on Washington. You were there and what, what memories stand out most vividly for you? Are there parts of that experience that come first to your mind when you think about it now?
Well, I remember just, you know, all the people they worked with to pull it off and then getting there and seeing everybody's, you know, a lot of SNCC people that I had met because I had gone to a couple of snake conferences.
All the people from SNCC folks coming up with community people and everybody being there and just so enthusiastic and so thinking that we would be full of hope, you know, full of hope that this is going to make a difference.
I've seen people from all walks of life, the children and all people and young people and entertainers and hearing the speeches and being there with our course of the course snake workers.
There was no violence, you know, pulling it off was just so inspiring because it wasn't a lot. So many people were speculating that something was going to happen and I hear all these people and then you had black, white, Asian people from all different backgrounds, different countries.
And it was out there and the weather was good. We didn't, you know, I mean, everything went well and so that was very exciting.
People that we knew and hearing the inspiring words of so many different people that were speaking.
You make your transition in the fall of 63 down to Jackson and will be in Mississippi for the next nine years and involved in a series of very interesting projects.
And we'll talk about those in sequence. I want to ask generally though if you could start by sort of painting a picture of the Mississippi you encountered in those years, especially early just when you, you know, soon year to after you arrived.
What were the most relevant things for you to to report if you were trying to help someone of a different generation now understand what that was like?
Well, I'll start with that first year. When I arrived, you know, I was given the title of a sneak field secretary and pulling the payroll for $10 a week.
That's what the sneak field secretary's made. And there were homes of people that Jackson folks that we would be put up with.
You'd stay with the family because you know, we didn't have money to pay for.
Of course, I had little savings that I had from my teaching. But we were, you know, put up with the family and then we were, you know, someone would pick you up to or the family would drop you off at the COFO office.
I was a counselor of federated organizations, which was an office that was an umbrella office. And so there were several snake, core, NAACP, all, you know, had people working there.
And the office was just buzzing with activity and initiatives relating to voter registration and demonstrations and integration of facilities and organizing counties and organizing a mock election governor's election.
And so there were two people coming in, needing orientation and working together to put on events or activities, mass meetings and coming together to plan, strategize, and as well as execute those things that need to be done to make that activity or event a success.
So I think a big thing was that the main thing was not that everything had been cleaned out in advance because you didn't know what was going to happen the more days of the next.
But it was the attitude that you all had, that it's time for us to do something. And we're going to take it day by day, be creative, work hard, value the community people.
And we're going to make changes. And we're open to seeing what it is we have to do to make those changes. And we're going to be creative in terms of making changes with young people, changing with older people, getting people out and doing positive activity to me to go.
We knew that we were having a lot of obstacles put in our paths that it was danger.
We couldn't rely on the police, we couldn't rely on the FBI, we could rely on ourselves and the people in the community.
It was a productive period, but it was scary to assert in a way.
We did realize that it was important to have the media coming in.
And they were demands that the media, the big networks, have black people coming in. They're not going to just have a white, you know, an all-white crew each time and at the movement was integrated.
Another thing that happened is when we saw that when something happened to children of white families that young people who were there, he got a lot more publicity.
But it was important to make sure that reporters really knew what was going on.
We had, it was interesting that we had some white southerners who joined the movement and who had important roles to play also, not only in the black community and the white community.
And we just kept being creative and coming up with ideas to respond to what was happening and to plan and to study how things were so convoluted and how they were so stacked against us.
But where were the little cracks in the dam?
How did you find your way forward most successfully crossing that space between your education and background outside the South and the conditions that you would find in rural black Mississippi in those years?
It wasn't such a big divide, you know. My parents and my grandparents were used to go camping from time I was very small. We used to go up to the mountains in New York and camp out, we had us to be bags and maybe for a week or so.
And I grew up with that. I also grew up as I said being very handy because that's how my father was.
We worked together as a family inside the house as well as outside the house in the church.
And so this was, it wasn't hard for me to adapt people to be in part of it like an extended family.
It didn't, strangers didn't, I wasn't afraid of strangers, it wasn't, you know, it was trusting trust.
Yeah, what was the expression, snake, a band of sisters and brothers in the circle of trust?
And if you would see what the people who lived there, what they had to give up and what they were willing to lose, then, I mean, they were so brave and spiritual.
I mean, if you would hear them talk and it was like, they were so spiritual and religious and we got that from them as well.
So we gave them certain kind of spirit and expertise and they gave what they had and together we just able to do so much.
Their determination, they were not afraid even though they knew full well what could happen even more than we did.
Can you reflect a little bit about the roles that were available to you as a woman, say in relation to all the other folks active in the movement at different levels inside SNCC and local grassroots and local communities.
Was that an active question in your mind in those days, your status as a woman in that mix?
Well, some people talk about that but really that never faced me.
I always did what I wanted to do.
I had my own inner drive and I found that when I came up with ideas and I was ready to work to see it through and I think that happened a lot of women in saying, we needed all hands on deck.
So we found ourselves in situations we had to rely on whoever was around and if somebody had XYZ skills and somebody only had ABC, we had to come together.
We used to joke about that but in reality the women were strong.
The women were strong.
When you see the young girls, teenagers who got arrested and what they had to go through they were in jail in these small, these rural areas.
These jails were two sides to it.
Not no facility really for women but they were willing to go and get arrested because they were going to demonstrate against certain things, stand up for it.
When you were in an integrated car and you had an out of state license plate or something, whoever was in that car was women or men or black or white or other.
You knew that there was danger, potential danger.
The book ends on the Frieden Plough talks about all of the different types of experiences that we had.
I remember when a couple of us were going to call and we decided to stop at the gas station.
I think in the early 70s, I went to the bathroom.
This is a men and women and others.
I was going to go in the women and the guy comes over to me and he pushes his sweater jacket over to the side and he shows me this big gun.
Just a look, maybe one sentence.
That is the situation right there.
We left.
You never knew when a situation was going to come up like that.
How you going to react would you go?
We had a certain goal.
We knew what we needed to do. That wasn't the time.
I think I was going to ask about John Kaleep, pause just one second.
Let me ask about, I think late in the fall, October 63, you and a couple others began the conversations that would lead to the creation of the Free Southern Theatre.
I would love to have you tell that basic story and what you imagined you wanted to do with that work.
John O'Neal and I and a couple of others were a part of the adult literacy project.
John had a background in theatre.
He was also a snake person from Carbondale, Illinois.
There was a young man Gilbert Moses, who was from Cleveland, Ohio, who also had a background in theatre.
I was doing a lot of art painting.
We were housed on Tougaloo College campus.
He was a German teacher who wanted to teach art.
He didn't have an art teacher.
He taught art on his own.
He had a classroom.
I think a lot of people used to go there and paint and talk about what we were doing.
My ears were art and dance.
I used to go to a lot of off-board way and board way plays, off-board way, black theaters, theatrical groups in New York.
The great thing about New York is all of the exposure to the arts that I had.
I was always looking for it that quests were black images in theatre, in film, in magazines and so on.
Visual art.
We were working in the literacy project.
There was so much going on, so much drama.
There was a professor of theatre on Tougaloo's campus, Bill Hutchinson, a white guy.
Bill Burt was the editor of the Mississippi Free Press.
He was around it, different things.
Even though we worked on the literacy project, we were still working going to the COFO office every day and involved with those projects.
We, in the COFO office, tried to recruit people to do something perhaps with the literacy project, as well as the other participating activities that Snick had going on.
We just started talking. One day was the three of us and we just said, you know, we need to have so much material here for plays.
A theatre group could write plays about different issues related to the movement, as well as bring scripts that, writings that are being produced in the north so that people could be exposed to all of this.
We just said, you know, we need to start a theatre.
In the theatre, we thought of the theatre as the vehicle and the housing for the other arts.
So we could have plays that, you know, I had the music and dance, and I would do the dance group and we'd have the need to have the art, you know, the stage and the backdrops and all of this.
And so we said, well, let's write something, you know, so we wrote why we wanted to be so, a theatre.
And we called it a free-sub-there because we wanted to take the plays out to the rural areas, go round and perform out in the cotton fields or in the church.
You didn't have a whole lot of community centers, just in certain places.
There was one big grocery store, like gigantic grocery store, that had a play in there.
It's like wherever you can have a place where people can congregate, outside or inside.
And so we said, well, let's think now that we need to see about contacting some people in New York to get scripts and see if we can get some people to come down and work on this and also recruit students from Tougaloo College and Jackson and see what issues we want to get.
We want to talk about, in conjunction with SNCC, like if perhaps develop a play about voting and the good things about being able to vote and so on and so forth.
So we wrote a perspective and then we decided we were going to go to New York and make contact and try to raise money and so on and so forth.
And also we started producing plays and we got Bill Hutchinson involved and he liked the idea.
So that's how it began and actually it lasted for 19 years.
It did move, the base moved to Tulane University in New Orleans and John and Gilbert went with it and I stayed.
Do you remember, I think the theater's first performance was summer 64, Freedom Summer.
I think in Macomb, Mississippi, I don't know if you maybe were there or not.
I was not there but we had the first first plays where in the spring of 64 at the rural campus, we did pearly victorious.
Can you describe that just a little bit?
Or maybe the better question is, you're sense of how your early work in various communities, how the outcomes matched up against your hopes and objectives?
Well, pearly victorious, we did that on campus.
And the literacy project, so we spent the majority of that spring trying to raise money and get publicity and getting it together.
But we did have the play, the pearly victorious.
The literacy project was a year long pilot and Bob was trying to get some more money for that to continue.
People who were overseeing it, the project coordinator was from New York.
And it didn't look like we were running. We only had a little bit of money left.
So we decided to take the project to New York and have the target group, the people who had moved to New York from South Carolina.
So we were going to keep the project for until the end of December, going with the methods that we were developing and see if we get the money continued.
So I decided that I would go back with it to continue.
John was going to stay in Mississippi, but they were also talking about possibly moving it to Tulane because the Richard Schechner, who was in charge of the theatre department at Tulane University,
liked the idea of the theatre and offered to house it there because Tulane was more money.
So I disagreed with that. And then the literacy project, I decided to go back and see the literacy project, see if that would, if we could get the grant and if we could come back, we didn't get the grant.
So I said I'm going back and there was a professor from the University of Michigan who was doing a research project on looking at achievement by black students in predominantly white schools versus in predominantly black schools.
And they needed one other person to help with the study for the spring of 65.
So I joined that group and we did our research at Tougaloo College College, Talladega College and Tuskegee.
We did Tuskegee first, I believe. Tuskegee even Talladega College and Tougaloo College.
Did you have to stop for this movement?
Somebody had heard about me being in the area, being a teacher.
And so they came and asked me would I be interested in working the HANSTAR program?
And I was very interested in it.
I had taught the third grade. I also had taught during summers, sometimes I worked in daycare programs at church and that kind of thing.
But again, this was a move that was not going to be like the standard.
It was going to be very different because you had conditions where you had the whites that didn't want us to have it.
And you had the black teachers who had regular teaching jobs did not, they were afraid to be associated with the HANSTAR program.
So teachers had to be recruited, they had to be trained, we had to find perhaps individuals who had one, two, three years of college or high school graduates who had their own little daycare program.
Who were good with children, who were mothers of large families and who were interested in this.
And so recruitment of teachers and training, setting up some, again, identifying facilities.
That was a whole, there was a whole big push.
And how far could you get out and reach people?
Well, you know, some people, some farmers had big plots of land.
So in some cases, they had a building or they were willing to build one to house a HANSTAR program.
And the churches for the most part were used.
So I was recruited to be a teacher for a center outside of rust, outside of holly springs.
We had our orientation at rust college for the teachers who were around in that, that county.
So I'm trying to think of the name of the school.
I was like, I can't think of it.
But I was the resource teacher for that center.
So I did a lot of things like, I had our teachers, the helpers, we made toys for the kids to play with out of recycle things.
They are most of my thing with recycle.
So I got tires and we painted some, the tires and put them in different places and made designs and horses that you use to make.
We used to build, we put, got pieces of wood and had them, put them over the dead horse, make it like a sea sore.
A lot of different things.
I was familiar with horses, wooden horses which my father used to use all the time.
And we got the wood and for the sea sore and sanded down.
And then we didn't have a lot of materials and books and things.
So I had the idea of the children, we showed them things, we do things with them and then had them react, for example, to pictures or something.
And then take notes on what they said or record what they said and then turn it into a book.
So we made our own books.
Excuse me, could you, my name?
I got local musicians, identified local musicians, had them come to the center and perform and prepared the books, make brown books for kids.
Just all kinds of things.
I really enjoyed it.
We had an orientation with the different teachers.
So later on, like in the middle of summer, I guess it was Polly Greenberg who was the director, they wanted me to come and be a troubleshooter teacher, a trainer at a couple of other centers.
And then the first one was the center in Durant.
The child development center in Durant was in the building that the community had donated, one person donated the land.
And the community members had come together and built it out of those cement slabs.
It was a really nice facility.
You mean the black community specifically?
The black community.
I had come together and it was a beautiful building.
It's because the majority of, I'd say majority, they had started selling the property in churches.
So I enjoyed that during that time, Adam Gifford from England was hired to make a movie, a documentary film about that head start.
They chose that head start center and then I was the lead teacher in that.
The movie was called Chance for a Change.
And they had different versions of it that they used for different reasons.
Let me ask about a next major initiative that you undertook and were involved with for a number of years through the late 60s.
That was the Poor People's Corporation, excuse me, and its connection then to its elements including Liberty House and Southern Media.
Well the Poor People's Corporation was an umbrella organization to promote, especially to promote economic development opportunities.
So one of the things that it had that it promoted was the establishment, promoted and facilitated the establishment of cooperatives.
The majority of them were handcraft cooperatives.
There were a few farmers cooperatives and we provided assistance to people who wanted to start cooperatives.
And so it would be, they might be started by a group of individuals or by what are the grassroots organizations in the particular area.
So several, just promoting the atmosphere of self-help and cooperation working together.
That was a movement really that took hold in Mississippi, in Louisiana and Georgia.
The Poor People's Corporation started the handcraft cooperatives and the Liberty House marketing.
You saw that if people are going to produce crafts, handcrafts, they have to have access to raw materials to buy in quantity.
Then there has to be a place to store the raw materials and the finished goods.
There has to be a place to keep the business aspect.
Then there has to be an arm for marketing.
So all of that, you decide to have that, that was going to be in Jacksonville.
The handcraft cooperatives were established throughout the state.
We had certain minimum requirements for persons who wanted to establish a co-op.
One of the things I did, they were a handful of us.
One of the things that I did was to, we worked through SNCC offices in other parts of the state.
They knew that we would send someone to a group, made a group of people who thought they would like to start their own co-op.
I would go out and talk to people, we need to have at least ten people to start this co-op.
You have to have a little bit of seed money and you have to find a place.
Here are some of the things that you have to do.
If you think you can do that, contact us and come back up.
We will arrange to have someone come and teach you how to make a certain hand, some particular handcraft.
We would look at what was already being produced.
Who do we have around that can, that has been, would be willing to go to that workshop for a period of time,
depending on what it is, how long it would be they would be needed.
We recruited volunteer crafts persons from the north to come and spend time in the co-ops.
Sometimes they couldn't really stay as long as it was going to be needed to keep that development going and quality.
They would teach me how to do something or it might be a short time.
I would find out from somewhere how to do something, go somewhere, for example.
I went somewhere and I was taught how to make candles.
I came back and went to the co-op.
I stayed there for a period of time and taught them how to make candles.
Someone came and taught a group how to make leather goods.
I was taught also, I did a little of that.
Then I was in the position to go back and kind of check it.
Some of the different things we call education and training for co-operatives, ETC.
Was there a book made of your favorite co-op that you had?
A favorite?
Not really.
Well, I really liked the leather goods.
Those were nice.
I liked the black dolls.
The Yuna sewing co-operatives.
We made the black rag dolls, male and female.
That was really an important move, I think, at that time, because black dolls were not readily available.
That was a big seller.
Unfortunately, I don't have one of those left.
I end up giving away to a lot of relatives, children.
I should thank you here for bringing so many examples of Liberty House handcrafts to share with us before we started today.
Well, there was the America I am exhibit that traveled across the country last year and the year before.
They had a few of my items, including my snake blue jean dress, jumper dress.
The guys had a blue jean jumper dress.
I was wondering where they are now.
Right.
When you think about the, that span through the late 60s, you were also heavily involved in Southern media.
That connects to your long practices and artists.
You had a camera with you, I think, when you probably first went into Mississippi and then became probably even more systematic with your photographic work.
I am really interested to have you talk about the whole experience of having a camera in your hands in Mississippi all those years.
When I first went, I didn't really take a lot of pictures because I was painting and I was more interested in that.
But in 68, Southern media was started in 1967 by two white guys from California, one maybe from California, one from Midwest.
They had come to Mississippi to make a documentary about what was going on in Mississippi.
But after they were there, they thought that they really needed to be able to train young blacks to make our own movies and pictures and documents have the skill.
So they looked around, they made one guy who was a trainee and they kind of made a little movie about Southern media and what the purposes were to go out and make films about different activities taking place, how people were living and what was going on with the movement and so on.
So they came to the Poor People's Corporation, Liberty House. They kind of had a hard time recruiting people.
I think the guy that you guys, Bill Pellets and Gear Morton, they weren't going to be able to stay there indefinitely.
So they wanted to leave it in the hands of, like, the equipment and the ideas in the hands of some people that had a stable place and had access to people who might be interested.
So they came to us and I always was the experimenter, the one that, okay, we have a project, let's do it, okay, you do it.
And so I said, okay, I'd like to do it. And so they, I have a healthy crewed as well as be part of it.
So that's what we did. We would go to different travel and to different places. This was something I did, part of the time.
I was still working with Liberty House. I was doing marketing and PR and sales promotion for Liberty House,
traveling throughout the country on, making appearances on television, radio, newspaper magazines, going to companies, going to retail stores to see if they would handle our products, going to wholesale places.
But I'd say, and then when I would come back for that time, I would answer letters that were sent to me as a result of the PR I was doing.
I might, in between if we had a new co-op to store it, I might go out to that for a little while. But then I also was, let's see.
I would also spend a lot of time with Southern media. And I had always liked to document things.
Our family always kept in mind stories and keeping records. And so I was called like the family historian.
Because I was always listening to my grandparents and writing things down about what they said and so on and so forth.
So that's how I got involved with Southern media. And I just stayed with it and brought back all these photographs.
And the thing is, you know, a lot of people, there are other people who took pictures. The question is, where are they? What are they going to do?
You might have, they were a couple of guys, they're guys in the N.I. group. But one is deceased now. Maybe one of the other ones is actually two out of that were deceased. And probably another guy is deceased who is much older.
So I thought that it was just really time, like in the 90s.
80s, I had a few starting to exhibit, but the thing is I'm doing other things at full-time jobs.
But there's a group here that I would say really is helpful to me in being able to do more with exhibits, to facilitate it.
And we had the Black Women's Photography Collective Call, Cistography. And I became a member of that.
So the main thing I had to do was get the photographs together, start to look at the negatives and contact sheets.
But they would, all we would organize the exhibit, they would have a curator, you drop your pictures off. And if you had time, you could help put them up if not.
Somebody would be doing it and we'd have a reception artist taught. So I'm still a part of that group and it's still very helpful to me.
What do you see when you look at those photos today? You think about your years in Mississippi? What's in those images?
It stands out most for you.
Well, I'll tell you, the women in all walks of life doing so many things with hemicelarides from men.
Then there's the children and their faces. What's happening with them? What do they see? How are they being influenced? What would they do tomorrow?
And then the men. You have these stereotypes about Black men. But my photograph show men doing very constructive kinds of activities.
And they were all there for the movement in so many different ways.
The flourishing of the development and flourishing of the co-ops, the farmers co-ops and the handcraft co-ops.
And then you had the housing co-ops and then you had the partnership between Tufts University and the Mound Bayou.
You saw a healthcare reform, healthcare medical reform and outreach. You saw educational outreach and reform. You saw economic development.
I'm recording all those things and I want those things to get out because those are still issues today.
But I want to show, I will always want to show, our images in the arts. Because if you pursue the arts and you're creative, you'll find a way to deal with everything.
But if you're only mind-centered, if something happens and you can't figure it out, and you think that's the only way you can be able to achieve it, then you may not have the confidence that you can.
But if you have a creative energy about you, you're going to always find a way to do things.
And so that's why I have this, I started a theatre group here on campus.
And also in African-American filmmakers group, we just started that this year.
And so I see the same reasons for starting those things then, and even more so now.
We have a lot of students who are interested in film on campus.
Let me ask you the last question that I have for you, and then we'll make sure that we pause and recap any other things that we should come back with.
But I'd love to hear you talk a little bit about, you've described yourself and kind of your life philosophy in some ways as a black womanist.
And can you describe how you think about that issue and what you mean when you say black womanist?
Well, you know, Alice Walker, she described it briefly.
I mean, I don't really go into long philosophical discussion about it.
I thought that perhaps she defined it as good.
It was a black woman working alongside of ending a junction with her family and her community to develop the community
to bring our people forward.
And it's not to say, well, the women need to be doing this and forget about the man we're going to do it.
So I know it's a group thing. It's a holistic approach, I think.
And that's basically how I feel about it.
And I think that the age-wise, you know, all the ages together, you've got to influence the children.
You've got to take the children with you to expose them from an early age when I think about the things that my father exposed me to, my mother, the family, seeing each other, relatives, all the time on the holidays, having those discussions.
And the same things. You see, they had those discussions before I was in the picture.
That's what I realized.
Even though I didn't know that my grandmother and my oldest uncle on my mother's side were charter members of the NAACP, I know now that they discussed those things.
And my aunt, Judy, went, was recruited and agreed to go to Washington.
It's because that atmosphere that growing up, those discussions and the not hiding things from them, some people, today they want, or even back some years ago.
And don't let the kids hear what's happening. Keep them away from that.
But we discussed things. The political.
Now I never knew what my father and how he voted. He didn't discuss that.
But we talked about the issues. We read about them. We encouraged to read about them.
We got, we had Ebony and other magazines that keep you informed to a certain extent.
And we encouraged to go read and research for ourselves.
So, that's really what I'm about. I'm not following any, like a doctorate.
It's really a reflection of how I love children, pause for just a sec.
Dr. Derby, I want to just say a special note of thanks for your energy and seriousness and all the time this afternoon and early evening here to contribute as you have to the series. Thank you very much.
Well, thank you. I enjoyed doing it. And I look forward to hearing, getting the copy of the tape and a transcript if you do.
Absolutely. That's definitely something we'll do. Thank you again so much.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.